Guten Morgen Linus. Du klingst irgendwie ein bisschen weit weg.
Buchnetzpolitik, die, na, hundertfünfte, hundertfünfte Ausgabe, genauso sieht's aus. Hier ist Tim und da ist Linus und, äh, ist ganz weit weg.
Ja ja,
Merkt man aber gar nicht, ne, weil wir so gute Qualität haben, weil wir qualitätsbewusste Podcaster sind, merkt man das gar nicht. Wenn wir schon den, wenn wir schon diesen diesen äh weiten Rekord jetzt nicht schaffen, den Höhenrekord hältst du ja, glaube ich, mit Maha, ne, als der irgendwie im Flugzeug saß.
Ja. Das kann gut sein, auch wenn ich's nicht genau benennen kann, wie hoch das war.
Den Distanzrekord hältst du auch knapp. Haben wir gerade ausgerechnet? Ja sicher.
Also unter uns auf jeden Fall. Ja, stimmt. Achttausendachthundertfünfzig Kilometer war bisher mein weitester äh Podcast-Distanz.
Genau und damit schlägst schlägst du ganz knapp den Nils K.
Der hat schon gebreakt, dass er irgendwie mit achttausendsiebenhundertfünfzig ja uneinholbar ist.
Ja, der hat da ja Hochmut kommt vor dem Fall, ja, ja.
So sieht's aus. Aber am Ende äh.
Keinen Blumentopf jetzt.
Ja genau, aber am Ende zählt ja sowieso nur die Qualität. Stimmt's?
Tonqualität und die ist natürlich hier ganz köstlich, ganz vorzüglich.
Ja ich ich meinte ja eigentlich die inhaltliche Qualität, die ist ja manchmal auch nicht ganz zu verachten. Da wird's ja jetzt schon ein bisschen schwierig, Dinos.
Ganz dünnes Eis. Könntest du das Eis? Ja, äh ist irgendwas passiert.
Nö.
Hört dann.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall nichts zu sehen. Gehen sie bitte weiter, ne. Also ist ganz klar.
Ja, irgendwie ist alles klar, nach wie vor ist immer noch alles irgendwie total äh wuschig.
Ja, für für die für die historischen Hörerinnen, die das jetzt alles so nach inne aus den Archiven gekratzt haben. Wir befinden uns in der Woche, in der der Spiegel titelte mein Nachbar NSA. Und endlich,
jetzt hier etwas rausdokumente zur Verfügung gestellt werden, die der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss braucht,
Das war ja auch so die Begründung, die die das Spiel genannt hat, so gesagt, ja, irgendwie Sicherheitsbehörden und Politiker fragen die ganze Zeit danach, aber wir sind halt Journalisten und wenn wir was verfügbar machen, dann halt auch für alle. Also hier bitte schön.
Was ich schon mal ganz gut fand, so als als Einstellung, ja.
Ja.
Ja und stellt sich raus, wer hätte es gedacht? Deutschland ist äh der wichtigste Standort äh der NSA innerhalb Europas und liefert Daten, die dabei helfen, Terrorverdächtige zu töten.
Zu töten. Ist das nicht verboten? Ach so, ja.
Nee, ist ja bei Terror, sind ja Terrorverdächtige, ne, weißt du ja, wie viel Leben das rettet. Und ähm die NSA arbeitet zusammen mit natürlich BND, äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz,
aber zum Beispiel auch mit dem BSI. Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Ach, steht da in irgendeiner Form äh wie diese Zusammenarbeit aussieht?
Details gibt's natürlich immer äh dann nicht äh beziehungsweise wenn es welche ernsthaft welche gibt, dann sind sie ja so schwarz angestrichen,
Aber das ist ja, da finde ich's ja wieder schön, ne,
Was hat der Neumann noch vor ein paar Wochen gesagt? Löst das BSI aus dem äh Bundesinnenministerium raus ähm oder aus der also macht es unabhängig, denn es besteht dort ein Interessenkonflikt und
Stellt sich raus, besteht gar kein Interessenkonflikt, die arbeiten schon längst mit der NSA zusammen, ja. Ähm,
Insgesamt äh spionieren in Deutschland mehr als zweihundert US-Agenten, die offiziell mit Diplomatenstatus akkreditiert sind. Das finde ich geil, das wollte ich als Kind immer haben. Kennst du Diplomatenstatus, ist geil, ne?
Wenn man beliebig äh viel falsch parken darf und schnell fahren darf und keiner kann einem was. Und außerdem immer und irgendwie schnell durchgleiten am Flughafen und so. Keine Schlangen, nichts. Wahrscheinlich wirst du noch nicht mal gecheckt irgendwie.
Kannst die ganze Zeit dein Dob rein und raus tragen. Ist geil.
Das wollte ich als Kind schon haben. Das war mir als Kind schon klar, irgendwie mit mit zehn Jahren, dass das echt was wert ist so. Ja und davon haben wir zweihundert. Das kannst du ich meine, parken oder so, ne? Überleg mal, was du da über die Jahre sparst.
Allein mit dem ganzen Koks handeln, ne, was du da nebenbei machst,
also das ist echt.
Ja, da ist was dran. Ja, das sind alles so äh Antaperatories und das ist äh ja, also man es hätte ja, es hätte ja was aus uns werden können. Linus. Und jetzt sind wir Podcaster.
Ja, aber ja, jetzt sind wir Podcast da mit reinem Gewissen, aber mit einer müden Mark nur in der Tasche.
Immerhin.
Reines Gewissen ist, reines Gewissen ist teuer Tim, reines Gewissen, kann ich nur sagen, ist teuer.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch wirklich, also es ist ja auch lässt einen ja so gut schlafen.
Na ja, unten mehrere hundert Angestellte äh privater Firmen sind auch noch hier unterwegs. Ähm
Ich meine, dass die Jungs Diplomatenstatus haben, ist sicherlich noch das kleinste Problem. Ähm
dann wurden einige Standorte der NSA genannt, aber da jetzt endlich nichts Neues. Bad Aibling, äh Komplex, das sind ja alles schon nach wie vor auch Ziele von Protesten.
Ja, beziehungsweise Spaziergängen.
Genau. Er ist Spaziergang, Entschuldigung, genau,
Hauptquartier unterhalten Sie in Stuttgart auch das war jetzt nichts neues dann haben Sie in Frankfurt am Main und natürlich auch die US-Botschaft in Berlin als,
Standorte ihres Wirkens, die NSA in Deutschland.
Ja, aber das ist ja alles nicht wirklich jetzt neu, oder? Also es ist ja gut, das mit dem BSI äh wurde, glaube ich, so bisher noch nicht erwähnt, aber an sich ist das jetzt nix Neues.
Nö, in Neu ist halt dann was an diesen Standorten betrieben wird und das äh schöne Projekt Rampart A,
aus dem mehr als drei Terrorbit pro Sekunde fallen, für die NSA, die aus der Glasfaser geholt werden,
Und zwar äh insgesamt also Wert aus Glasfaser und aus anderen Kollektionsorten ähm,
was insgesamt dreiunddreißig NSA Drittstaaten, werden Daten gesammelt,
typischerweise, in dem ein Partnerland an einem Zugangspunkt innerhalb der eigenen Grenzen Kabel anzapft,
in dreizehn Fällen ist das halt auch Glasfaser,
und von diesen dreizehn Ländern oder von den dreiunddreißig Drittstaaten, da bin ich jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, wie das genau war. Ich hab's mir nur notiert, wurden jetzt nur Deutschland und Dänemark identifiziert.
Und,
dann haben sie die Journalisten hingegangen und haben so verschiedene äh äh Deduktionen gemacht und festgestellt, dass im März zweitausenddreizehn,
Angestellte, die nicht wussten, was sie da taten,
in einer Telekommunikationsanlage ein Kabel gefunden haben vor, was irgendwie in ihrem High-Level-Design nicht verzeichnet war,
und das hieß und da stellte sich dann auch raus, dass es im Rahmen, dass das halt Teil von war,
und ähm.
Was stand da dran? War.
Nein, das stand da nicht dran, aber also so irgendwie.
Wurde es genannt.
Als das hatte sich dann stellte sich dieses Kabel dann heraus, weil dann irgendwie in den NSA-Reports dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder drin stand, ja hier, hm, da ist einer übers Kabel gestolpert. Scheiße und ähm,
so fügt sich das alles zusammen. Aber wir haben ja eine Einigung, wir haben nämlich eine Einigung, nämlich nicht gegenseitig zu spionieren,
Ausnahmen. Also teilweise gibt's dann da Ausnahmen steht auch auf der Folie,
also eigentlich aber es gibt natürlich Ausnahmen. Zum Beispiel gab's eine für äh Bad Aibling,
Ja, aber grundsätzlich ist es auch Teil der Vereinbarung. Achtet man natürlich alle Gesetze,
Grundsätzlich achtet man alle Gesetze, außer bei Terror oder wenn eines der beiden Enden im Ausland ist,
und jetzt fügt sich halt langsam dieses Bild äh zusammen von diesem Ringtausch, ne, dass alle sich an die Gesetze halten,
und ähm die Geheimdienste dann untereinander diesen Ring tausch machen, ne? Das ist schon.
Das ist wirklich super, also äh das heißt, es gibt da irgendwie so ein Kabel, das geht von A nach B. In A gilt die Rosdiktion A
Die sagt, äh ihr dürft hier alle ablauschen, bloß nicht A und auf der anderen Seite äh B
gibt's die alle ablauschen aber nicht B, aber an beiden Seiten sitzen halt irgendwie die selben Leute, ja? Also man muss sich das mal so vorstellen als würde so der Gotthardtunnel ja irgendwie sozusagen auf beiden Seiten äh äh entsprechend äh kontrolliert werden und auf der einen Seite dürfen.
Du in einer Fahrtrichtung?
Ja ja genau und in der Einrichtung äh na ja Fahrtrichtung? Nö. Die Fahrtrichtung ist, glaube ich, bei den Daten ziemlich egal.
Denen geht's ja darum, also wenn ein Kommunikationspartner im Ausland ist ja sowieso nicht, also ich glaube, das ist auch jetzt, also natürlich hängen die da dran, so. Und die Deutschen machen mit und das erklärt auch.
Warum die da so rumeiern?
Warum die da so rumeiern.
Warum die das nicht aufklären wollen, weil dann würde das ja dann mal rauskommen.
Aber findest es nicht spannend, dass die also hm ich meine, das war ja eh immer,
Es war ja das Offensichtliche, ne. Das war irgendwie das war genau diese Konstellation, sind die Erklärungen dafür
dass die äh Bundesregierung darumeiert, dass die da nichts machen wollen, dass sie irgendwie dass sich ja noch vor ein paar Wochen dieser Sensburg ähm der Leiter, der Vorsitzende des Untersuchungsausschusses äh hinstellt und sagt, der Snord muss jetzt endlich mal liefern,
das doch ähm also es war, es war ja irgendwie.
Ja und jetzt hat er geliefert, oder? Snow hat geliefer.
Jetzt hat er, ihr ja, das Norden hat geliefert.
So, sie wollten die ganze Zeit die Dokumente haben und jetzt äh sind die Dokumente. Das ist schon wieder so ein Prack-Moment wie aus dem Anhalter. Ich glaube, ich hatte das äh hier schon ein paar Mal,
wiedergegeben diese tolle Szene wo sie alle schreien über Pack aus, pack aus, pack aus und dann fängt er an auszupacken und so nein nein nein und dann eine große Mauer in dir herumbauen, das bloß keiner zuhört, wenn er auspackt. Und so ähnlich ist das hier irgendwie mit diesem LSA Ausschuss auch wirklich
dich. Heißt der eigentlich offiziell wirklich NSA-Ausschuss oder äh.
Äh ach so, das weiß ich nicht, wie der, wie der, also er wird ja wird sicherlich irgendeine, irgendeinen anderen Titel haben, aber,
als der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Und da übrigens auch der äh der SPD-Obmann in diesem Gremium Christian Fielsäck gesagt, dass es eine willkommene Grundlage für unsere Arbeit, die werden wir jetzt rasch prüfen.
Es wird also wieder mal geprüft.
Naja, aber der will der der ist ja SPD, Konstantin von Notz, sagt natürlich auch, wir wollen mal sehen, was da drin ist. Also die freuen sich natürlich. Ich bin jetzt mal gespannt, wie lange das dauert, bis der zurücktritt und sich sagt ähm.
Ja, meine Kinder sollen leben.
Ja, aber es es ist jetzt mal spannend. Also, was mich jetzt interessiert, so rein ich gucke ja schon längst aus der historischen Perspektive darauf,
Wie wird diese Geschichte jetzt erzählt? Also hat es,
also wird es sich als strategisch klug herausstellen, diese Bombe erst so spät platzen lassen zu haben, mehr als ein Jahr nach den ersten Enthüllungen oder ähm,
hat man jetzt der Bundesregierung und ihren Erfüllungsgehilfen,
genug Zeit gegeben das so zu manifestieren,
als der NSA-Skandal mit dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss und dem bösen Ami, der äh der da irgendwie streckenweise wohl ein bisschen zu weit zu gehen scheint,
ja? Wenn ihr mal das falsche Telefon abhört. Ähm,
oder ist es wiederum so, dass man sagt, da dass man genau das jetzt endlich, nachdem sie so lange es aufgebaut haben mit diesen mit diesen Enthüllungen, mit dieser Meldung, schafft einstürzen zu lassen, um sie wirklich mit ähm Hose runter, da da stehen zu lassen.
Du meinst ja jetzt, ob ob wirklich diese Veröffentlichung genau dieser Dokumente jetzt gerade irgendwie besonders getimed war? Das ist das, was du jetzt.
Nee, ist ja egal, ob's also ob's jetzt gut getimt war oder nicht, ist unklar, äh ist egal. Die ähm äh die Frage ist, ob sie ähm,
ob sie sich als nachher in in historischer Betrachtung als richtig getimed herausstellen wird.
Nachher bin mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher, weil nachher hier äh irgendwie sein könnte, ja. Ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass wir dem äh schon besonders nahe gekommen sind.
Ja, das äh klingt für mich eher hier noch so ein bisschen wie so eine endlose Geschichte, über die wir auch noch in einem Jahr reden werden.
Ja, aber irgendwann muss ja mal was passieren, ne.
Ja, irgendwie passiert ja auch was. Ist halt nur so, dass mittlerweile äh,
das Ganze eben durch diesen fortwährende äh Herunterspielung irgendwie das Ganze auch so als,
ausreichend herunterspielt, bespielt gilt. So, also irgendwie ist es egal, welche Details jetzt noch dazu kommen. Es es gibt da einfach keinerlei ähm,
reaktive Nervenzellen mehr in der Öffentlichkeit, die jetzt auch irgendeine beliebige Steigerung überhaupt auch noch zur Kenntnis nehmen würde. Also du kannst jetzt auch noch sagen, dass sie irgendwie,
Ja, weiß nicht. Also wenn sie Haustiere gequält haben, dann ist es unter Umständen nochmal eine Meldung wert so, ja. Also solche Belanglosigkeiten werden sicherlich gerne aufgegriffen. Aber es verbindet irgendwie keiner mehr die ganzen,
ähm die ganzen Punkte so, ne.
Das kann man ja auch gar nicht mehr.
Andererseits hatte ich äh hatte ich jetzt äh gestern oder war es heute, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, hatte ich auch das Gefühl, die Affäre ist eigentlich offiziell geändert, äh weil äh Sascha Lobo das erste Mal in seiner Spiegelkolumne über ein anderes Thema geschrieben hat.
Extra nochmal gesucht, da war von NSA, also das Wort Geheimdienst und NSA kam da nicht drin vor,
Tja. Soweit ich den Podcast jetzt hier auch erstmal beenden für ein Jahr.
Nee, das war halt das hat dann endlich ausgelöst, dass die Spiegel Leute gesagt haben, okay, jetzt können wir jetzt hauen wir das raus.
Wenn schon Sascha Lobo nicht mehr drüber schreibt, ja. Ja,
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, ist ja nicht so, mit diesen Dokumenten muss man sich das nicht so vorstellen, dass sie so alle äh ausgedruckt so in fertigen Häppchen da auf dem Tisch liegen haben, uns nur noch die Frage, was sie nochmal auf dem Fotokopierer liegen. So und das sind halt alles Dokumente, die in gewisser Hinsicht,
ausführlich äh durchgelesen werden müssen,
werden müssen und in Zusammenhang gestellt werden müssen. Äh natürlich gilt auch da dieser äh schon von Greenwelt hochgehaltene Kodex, das keine Namen genannt werden, beziehungsweise eben nichts
daraus publiziert wird, was dann von einer Staatsöffentlichkeit schnell als ihr gefährdet ja hier unsere Soldaten et cetera interpretiert werden kann. Ich meine, es es wird natürlich im öffentlichen Diskurs,
trotzdem so äh.
Diskutiert, als wäre das geschehen. Das haben wir ja bei auf der Republika äh gesehen, der glaubt das ja auch. Ja, nur ähm immerhin hält es der Überprüfung noch stand. Das ist so, zumindest meine Erkenntnis nachher noch, nirgendswo so gewesen ist.
Tja, also,
keine Ahnung. Vielleicht bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei diesen Dokumenten, was jetzt eigentlich irgendwie äh bekannt geworden ist. Eigentlich ich finde erstmal diese Zahl irre,
sieben, nee, Entschuldigung, drei Terrabit,
Als ihrer Netzpolitik Org hat das irgendwie mal ausgerechnet, ich hab's jetzt äh noch nicht nach äh rechnen können, aber es seien dreihundertzweiundsechzig Millionen CDs pro Tag,
Muss ich echt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Dreihundertzweiundsechzig Millionen CDs pro Tag.
CDs Ketten ausgerechnet, also ich.
Ist einfach die Speicherkapazität nicht so definiert.
Ich finde dreihundertzwei, ich meine das ist irgendwie unklar. Also es ist einfach man möchte nicht mit so viel Festplatten äh beworfen werden wie die da irgendwie den ganzen Tag vollschreiben. Ich frage mich, wo sie das auch erst hinschreiben.
Also echt. Ich glaube auch nicht dran, dass die wirklich alles mitspeichern können. Das ist einfach irgendwo.
Dreihundertfünfundsiebzig Gigabyte pro Sekunde, zweiundzwanzigeinhalb Terabyte pro Minute,
eintausenddreihundertfünfzig Terabyte pro Stunde oder dreitausendzweiunddreißigtausendvierhundert Terabyte pro Tag,
ja. Also ich komme mir irgendwie cool vor, weil ich zwölf Teilarbeit speichern kann irgendwo.
Ja oder sich irgendwie zwölf Terabyte im Monat irgendwie an Datenübertragung habe, meinen Podcast, aber das hier ist irgendwie beyond.
Gut, ähm haben wir hier noch was?
Sprachlosigkeit natürlich, wir werden jetzt sehen, was sich da noch an an ach so, ja, also es gibt natürlich, es gibt ja einen kleinen, erlesenen Kreis in Deutschland, ne. Es gibt ähm ein paar äh Domains, die nicht überwacht werden,
Die sind ganz interessant.
Wo kommt denn diese Black Days überhaupt her? Auch aus.
Aus, aus auch aus diesen ähm auch aus dem Snowden.
Ah ja, stimmt. JSA Restriktions heißt das Dokument, genau. Mhm.
Und das ist ganz äh da gibt's also eine lange äh lange Liste. Kann man jetzt mal hier nochmal anschauen. Da sind natürlich einige,
ähm da sind natürlich einige schöne Lacher bei.
Ja, es ist erstaunlich,
Das ist vor allem erstmal keine Lacher dabei, also äh was hier ausgenommen ist, ist irgendwie sowas wie BRSF dot com, Ingelheim dot com
Bundeswehr dot org, äh Debitelnetz, DHL, com, ja, DS Net Eurocopter com, Mercedes Benz, das kann man irgendwie alles nachvollziehen, Rode und Schwarz, Siemens natürlich, auch alles solche,
Tütan bitte.
Rode und Schwarz ähm muss man vielleicht noch kurz erklären. Ich meine, Rode und Schwarz bauen ähm Telekommunikations- und Telekommunikationsüberwachungsequipment.
Mhm.
Die haben den im äh auf den Markt gebracht. Also es war ein Produkt von denen. Die bauen aber auch ähm also sie sind im Prinzip bei allem, was mit Telekommunikation zu tun hat. Ein Großer, der ein großer Kontraktor ähm,
ähm ein großer Vertragspartner, der, der allen deutschen, aller deutschen Behörden.
Der Bundesregierung ähm.
Der Bundesregierung. Und äh zwar dann auch im Militärbereich, ne. Bauen aber auch harmloses Zeug. Also sie bauen zum Beispiel auch Krypto-Telefone, ja.
Ja, aber dann sind auch so schöne Sachen wie Orgelbau dot com und Sernioren. Seniorenheim dot com.
Das denn? Das verstehen.
Und neuer, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Und während neue Einheit dot com klingt wirklich so, ja und die Feuerwehr Ingolstadt, Feuerwehr und Ingolstadt dot org.
Ja, werde? Ey, wenn die sogar noch mit mit denen unter einer Decke stecken, ne? Wenn die da sogar drin, also was ist das denn? Seniorenheim dot com.
Hast du nicht. Ich bitte dich, hast du nicht Illuminatus gelesen? Da sind die.
Erinnere mich das.
Die Nazihorden am Boden des Sees bei Ingolstadt werden die da äh warten sozusagen auf ihren Einsatz. Ist einfach mal alles absolut eins A Verschwörungsmaterial, was wir hier geliefert bekommen.
Seniorenheim dot com gehört dem Pflegezentrum Bischofsgrün in der Ochsenkopfstraße einundvierzig in Bischofsgrün. So, das das scheint ja ein Ort zu sein, den es gibt.
Ja, an was glaubst du, wer die Senioren da alles sind? Das sind alles ausgemusterte NSA-Agenten.
Mit Diplomatenstatus.
Ja, genau, mit Diplomatenstatus. Dot com, huhu, was die so für Orgeln bauen so, ja. Also, unfassbar, was diese äh Liste so hergibt und ähm,
ja und auch so merkwürdige es sieht alles ein bisschen merkwür.
Feuerwehr Ingolstadt handelt es sich um die freiwillige Feuerwehr. Aha. Aber die wurde achtzehnhundertdreiundsechzig gegründet, die Kette gab's die USA kaum.
Ähm.
Sie gerade mal irgendwie zweihundert Jahre oder so.
Aha. Illuminaten. Lassen wir das.
Okay, wir werden albern.
Wir werden albern. Na ja, ich meine, was da übernimmt ihr auch sonst machen.
Müssen wir noch kurz erzählen, der BND expandiert. Wir hatten das, glaube ich, auch vor einiger Zeit schon mal ähm,
geschrieben, dass sie ganz gerne äh dreihundert Millionen Euro hätten für die strategische Initiative Technik,
In der strategischen Initiative Technik möchten sie ihre ähm Möglichkeiten zur Echtzeitanalyse von äh Streaming-Daten äh nach dem Vorbild von äh NSA und GCHQ,
ausbauen,
Und das Interessante bei dieser, bei dieser Meldung war, dass halt gesagt wurde, ja, die haben dreihundert Millionen Euro beantragt für den Zeitraum zweitausendvierzehn bis zweitausendzwanzig, in der, in der Zeit wollen sie also dreihundert Millionen auf den Kopf hauen,
und,
Dann wurde in den Medien erst groß zelebriert einige Monate später oder einige Wochen später. Ja äh sie kriegen nur sechs statt der dreihundert Millionen,
ja? Also wollten dreihundert Millionen haben, äh kriegen nur sechs HH äh schön äh snowden, Enthüllung zeigen erste Wirkung. Es ist gerade politisch nicht opportun, das zu machen. Stellt sich aber raus,
die sechs Millionen waren nur für zweitausendvierzehn,
Das heißt, wenn du diese ähm wenn du diese dreihundert Millionen oder wenn das jetzt hochrechnest, auf die sechs Jahre, ne, dann kommen sie ja immer noch auf die dreihundert Millionen.
Mhm. Ah, verstehe.
Ja? Also da äh das zum Beispiel geht auch zurück auf eine schöne,
Enthüllung aus dem aus dem auf eine schöne äh Analyse aus dem Bereich der Linkspartei,
die jetzt also feststellt, die strategische Initiative Technik läuft genauso, wie sie geplant war. Das wollte ich noch mit erwähnt haben an dieser Stelle,
Und zwar, also wollen sie irgendwie zweitausendvierzehn sechs Millionen äh zweitausendfünfzehn achtundzwanzig Millionen zweitausendsechzehn vierundvierzig Millionen, das heißt, ihr die ähm also,
Der Finanzierungsbedarf war genauso angegeben.
Ich meine, das Interessante ist, wenn sie äh Echtzeitanalyse, Streaming-Daten machen, so wie NSA und wenn man aber eilig in den Dokumenten jetzt grade feststellt, dass sie das irgendwie sowieso schon mit betreiben,
traue ich mich natürlich, ob das jetzt sozusagen so eine Art Nachtragshaushalt ist. Das ist völlig völlig unkla.
Kann gut sein. Also ich mein, es ist es ist irgendwie völlig es ist einerseits völlig unklar und andererseits auch so offensichtlich, ne? Also ich meine, welchen Grund zu der Annahme haben wir überhaupt noch, dass da irgendjemand,
irgendwo sich an irgendeine moralisches Gesetz hält, ja? Geschweige denn an irgendein äh juristisches Gesetz.
Mhm. Das ist.
Es gibt da eine ähm eine schriftliche Zusammenfassung
anlässlich des ein, anlässlich des ein Jahr Snowdens
sich mit den mit den ähm Entwicklungen in den einzelnen Ländern auseinandersetzt, ähm die hatte uns auch einen äh höherer nochmal in den Kommentaren nahegelegt, ähm weil wir uns ja auch die Frage gestellt haben, wie diese ganze Affäre
oder diese ganzen Enthüllungen auch in anderen Ländern auf und wahrgenommen werden,
Da bin ich leider nicht dazu gekommen, das jetzt nochmal eingehend zu studieren. Das werden wir dann auch noch mal machen müssen.
Ja, wir werden nachliefern.
Wir werden nachliefern, ja. Aber es geht halt so, also was mich am meisten irgendwie wurmt, ist, dass es nach wie vor äh so weitergeht, ne. Also es ändert sich nicht so.
Ja, weil die öffentliche Meinung einfach nicht, nicht mitgezogen hat bei dem Thema. So sieht man das äh hat sich ja von Anfang an schon so abgezeichnet
Thema ist einfach nach wie vor zu komplex und zu wenig verstanden und äh entweder die Leute äh spüren es einfach nicht genug,
Ja, ist einfach keine Überwachung, die man bemerkt und das äh reicht offensichtlich.
Nichts ändert sich, verstehst du, selbst wenn du jetzt was dagegen tust, ändert sich nichts. Es fühlt sich immer alles noch genauso an.
Äh widmen wir uns doch ein paar weltlicheren Themen,
Ja
Ja, unsere Facebook-Seite wächst und gedeiht, ne? Ja, klar. Hier.
Tut sie das? Wodurch jetzt?
Äh Likes, Facebook-Seiten, durch Likes und ähm,
Oh, die Reichweite ist gesunken.
Wisst ihr das? Ja, das ist auch.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil die Arschlöcher jetzt das nicht mehr anzeigen und gelten haben wollen. Das ist ja echt, das ist wirklich unglaublich,
Mir ist völlig unklar, wie dieser, okay, lassen wir das. Aber nein, lassen wir nicht. Facebook ist scheiße. Also die wollen hier die ganze Zeit sagen sie, ja, hier willst du mehr Likes, ähm dann ähm,
Klick hier, äh gibst zweiundzwanzig Euro, gibt's mehr Reichweite oder so. Das ist echt das ist so eine Katastrophe,
Also liebe Leute, Facebook dot com log buch Punkt not netz Politik, bitte liken für Oma,
und und und scheren und und was nicht alles. Ich erreiche nämlich mein nächstes großes Ziel, fünfhundert gefällt mir Angaben will ich hier erreichen.
Ich bitte dich, Linus.
Ey, das ist eine also nee, wir machen das.
Ich komme mir vor wie in so einer schlechten Social Media Agentur.
Entweder das Ding hat irgendwie bis Ende dieses Monats am.
Ich sage, ich sage mal was anderes. Ich scheiße auf die Likes. Ich scheiße auf die Likes. Wenn ihr das einzige, was, nein, das einzige, was mich wirklich überzeugen würde, ist, wenn da nennenswertes Feedback käme,
Ja, was denn?
Ich habe hier einen Kommentar von Alexander Ken.
Aha. Ja, sehe ich auch.
Und von Slako von,
Lalasamboy, der hat sich aber nicht zum Thema geäußert,
den habe ich.
Understanding hätte man mehr ausgegeben dafür irgendwie. Das sind die Freunde, die man hier gekauft bekommt. Das ist ja nüscht.
Verstehst du? Das ist alles Fake irgendwie. Die Leute gibt es alles gar nicht,
das auch nicht, das ist einfach alles nur äh es ist einfach nur so Behauptung. Ich meine, du kannst ja mal bei Slatko, Sonja, Slala, Sambull mal irgendwie auf seine Seite gucken. Ja, es ist einfach mal, es geht gar nicht,
schlimm. Es ist alles nur Dreck.
Okay, also wenn das bis, wenn das bis was setzen wir uns als Ziel, was setzen wir uns als Ziel? Müssen wir jetzt irgendwie sagen, also bis zum dreißigsten Juni,
zweitausendvierzehn. Was wollen wir dahaben? Ich, ich, also fünfhundert Likes sowieso.
Was willst du da haben? Ich bin da überhaupt nicht für. Ich kann dir da nur mit mit äh Jusha Fischer, äh Joshka Fischer äh antworten.
Der war bei Facebook.
Nein. Grade hat die richtige Antwort gegeben.
So, aber eigentlich hatten wir ein ganz anderes Thema. Es geht nämlich hier um Facebook und
die rechtliche Auseinandersetzung um die generelle Frage, wie es denn so ist mit den europäischen Datenschutzbestimmungen und Facebook und inwieweit diese denn von Facebook einzuhalten sein und da äh gibt's ja schon seit etwas längerem eine Auseinandersetzung
Ähm wie heißt der Mensch nochmal?
Marc Shrimps. Ähm und ich glaube, wir hatten das auch schon mal im Programm gehabt, nicht wahr? Das ist aber schon eine Weile her, ne?
Der Typ, ich, der ist äh der ist Jurastudent und ähm,
Also der nutzt Facebook. Er hat jetzt vor Kurzem ähm,
worüber wir berichtet haben, ist, dass es ihm irgendwie gelungen ist, einen Schriftsatz aufzusetzen und von Facebook alle seine Daten zu bekommen. Die haben sie ihm dann damals in Form eines PDFs gegeben
Und dann hat er eben auch festgestellt, dass
Dinge, die er gelöscht hat von Facebook nur als gelöscht markiert werden und bei behalten werden. Und er hat dann für diese Möglichkeit gekämpft, dass man mit, dass man seine Daten dort mitnehmen kann
was natürlich ein ein wichtiges Anliegen des Verbraucherschutzes ist, dass man, wenn man bei der einen Datenkrake nicht mehr sein möchte, seine Daten
anderen opfern kann, ja? Und dass man damit allen mitgehen kann und so. Ähm solche Dinge hatte da bis jetzt ähm dann,
erkämpft, hat jetzt vor kurzem dann auch sein äh Buch äh veröffentlicht dazu, ne? Klar, schreibst du natürlich ein Buch drüber, ähm,
Kampf um meine Daten oder kämpf um deine Daten, heißt das Buch, weiß ich nicht mehr genau, ich glaube Kampf um meine Daten. Ähm dann gab's ein kleines Intermezzo mit Facebook, weil Facebook gesagt hat, ey ähm,
Sag mal das Buch, das bewirbst du bei uns aber bitte nicht. Ähm.
Und äh das haben damit sind sie dann natürlich auch durchgekommen. Ja und trotz all dem kämpf um deine Daten heißt das,
Ähm vor kurzem erschienen auf Facebook nicht zu bewerben. Ähm.
Aber äh der der junge Mann bleibt lässt nicht locker, er hatte ein ganz komisches Verhältnis zu diesem Facebook, denn er nutzt das nach wie vor weiterhin und hat sie aber jetzt äh direkt mal in Irland wieder mal verklagt. Ähm,
Und diesmal wegen der Weitergabe der Daten an Prisum. Also er hat gesagt, hier zeigt Facebook ähm gibt Daten weiter an,
an das Prison Programm oder und diese Daten werden im Rahmen des Prison Programmes genutzt,
und ähm das ist doch äh so erstmal nicht,
in Ordnung. Und dann hat er das Ganze erstmal angezeigt bei der irischen Datenschutzbehörde. Die PC und die meinten dann so, ne, ist schon okay, gehen sie weiter.
Dann ist er vor das oberste irische Zivilgericht den gegangen und hat äh Facebook da verklagt
und der Richter, der dort für den Fall zuständig war, Jared Hogan sagte dann, naja, es gibt Beweise dafür, dass persönliche Daten routinemäßig in massenhafter und undifferenzierter Weise von US-Sicherheitsbehörden eingesehen werden,
und dann kommt, sagt er, na ja, persönliche Daten dürfen laut dem Safe Harber-Abkommen nur ins Ausland gelangen,
Wenn die EU-Datenschutzrechte ausreichend gesichert sind. Und dieses Safehaber-Abkommen sagt ja, in den USA ist das der Fall Punkt.
Also hat der gute äh Mister äh Judge Hogan gesagt? Ähm,
das kann ich gar nicht in Irland entscheiden. Dieser Fall muss vor den EuGH,
und jetzt kommt der Max Shrimps mit dieser Sache. Facebook gibt Daten an ähm an im Rahmen des Present Programmes weiter und verstößt damit gegen europäische Datenschutz äh vor den EuGH,
auch sammelt auch Geld dafür grade,
Allerdings sei der Hinweis äh gestattet an der Stelle, dass ja Microsoft und Facebook weiterhin ähm nur von einer Datenweitergabe im Einzelfall sprechen und sich ja auch nach wie vor sehr beklagen,
ähm über die äh äh über die finanziellen Schwierigkeiten, die die US Internetindustrie seit einem Jahr erfährt.
Ja ja, die sind doch alle überhaupt nicht froh drüber, auch äh Apple nicht und alle anderen großen Cloud-Anbieter,
Amazon scheint mir nicht ganz so laut äh zu sein, aber es liegt wahrscheinlich da dran, dass ihr das ganze Hosting für die CIA machen. Also,
ist ja so. Also ähm,
Ich meine, wir reden jetzt von demselben EuGH, der noch vor Kurzem äh sich ja im Rahmen,
der umstrittenen Entscheidung, um diesen Spanier, der seine Einträge bei Google getilgt haben wollte, ähm,
äh du hast ja sicherlich auch die Sendung, die ich hier mit Anrege gemacht habe, nachgehört und wo andere ja auch nochmal ähm argumentiert hat, dass ähm,
wenn man da sehr unterschiedlicher Meinung drüber sein kann, dass äh eine mindestens eine interessante Aspekt in dieser Entscheidung der ist, dass hier das erste Mal vom EuGH auch klar gesagt wird, dass die europäische Juristi eben auch für Facebook gilt.
Äh entschuldige in dem Fall für für Google gilt aber eben allgemein daraus kann man eben ableiten oder könnte man ableiten das ist natürlich jetzt für alle amerikanischen Unternehmen gilt. Und äh dann natürlich auch,
im Bereich Datenschutz so. Also es ist ja in dem Sinne noch nie so richtig festgestellt worden und ähm das könnte ein sehr interessantes Ergebnis,
hervorbringen.
Ich bin auch mal gespannt, was also das wird der EuGH sicherlich auch ernst nehmen diese Angelegenheit. Die Frage ist dann, ob ähm ob man auf Basis dieser äh Snowdendokumente dann da ernsthaft auch ein Urteil sprechen kann.
Tja, weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht. Wird sich zeigen.
Im Moment wird auf jeden Fall Geld gesammelt. Ähm,
Ich glaube, unter Crowd for Privacy dot org, um äh sich dann dieses äh Gerichtsverfahren leisten zu können, denn so EuGH Sachen sind nicht so billig, allerdings,
Hat der da jetzt auch schon ausreichend Geld gesammelt? Also andere Beschwerden, die ich kenne, brauchten dann nicht direkt dreihunderttausend,
Ja, also er sagt, zwischen hunderttausend und dreihunderttausend, okay, das deckt sich jetzt nicht mit meinen mit den Preisen, die ich so kenne. Aber soll er mal ruhig haben.
Ja. Mit einer vier äh geschrieben.
Genau. Das ist echt ein ganz, ganz interessanter äh Fall, denn dieser Max ist jetzt vorher nicht irgendwie großartig als ähm,
Netzaktivist aufgefallen, das scheint echt einfach nur ein Facebook Fan mit einer sehr besonderen Beziehung zu seinen sozialen Netzwerk äh zu sein und ähm ja, mit einem,
mit einer auch sehr großen Leidenschaft für das Fach, was er da studiert.
Ja, neues Mal ist so schön zu sehen, dass so viele Leute äh unterstützen, ne.
Mehr solche Leute, mehr solche Leute.
Also zu diesem Zeitpunkt steht der Spendenbalken bei vierundfünfzigtausend Euro, was ja auch schon mal nicht schlecht ist.
Das ist erstmal nicht wenig, ja.
No. Gut. Was haben wir noch?
Noch jemanden, der klagt.
Ja, es wird gerne geklagt und zwar äh klagt jetzt die äh VG Media ein relativ junges äh Gebilde
von ähm modernen aufstrebenden Internetunternehmen. Man könnte auch sagen, den deutschen Verlagen
die sich da ja äh ich glaube, da hatten wir auch explizit als Thema neulich mal gehabt, ja, die sich da zusammen geschlossen haben. Das sind hundertachtunddreißig Unternehmen
die insgesamt zweihundertneunzehn digitale verlegerische Angebote sozusagen hier wahrnehmen im Rahmen einer Klage gegen Google, wegen des Leistungsschutzrechts
Das ist ja das, worauf wir eigentlich schon lange gewartet haben.
Also muss noch kurz zu der VG Media sein, die gibt's schon länger,
die gibt's seit zwölf Jahren noch nach eigener Auskunft, weil sie auch Radio und Fernsehsender vertritt
und in den letzten vergangenen zwölf Jahren brüstet sie sich, hat sie über vierhundert Millionen Euro für die durch sie vertretenen Unternehmen erwirtschaftet. Und das heißt, das ist im Prinzip die, die Unternehmen, die schließen sich dann dieser V
Verwertungsgesellschaft an,
damit die einheitlich äh diese Leistungs äh Schutzrechte dann da äh geltend macht, ja? Das heißt, es macht dann nicht jeder Verlag einzeln. Auch da einzeln. Auch darüber hatten wir ja mal ähm,
philosophiert, ob das so passieren würde. Nein, die schließen sich dann einfach alle. Einer Verwertungsgesellschaft an. Genauso wie andere Verwertungsgesellschaften,
VG Wort, die GEMA und so. Das sind ja alles so Verwertungsgesellschaften, in die halt Leute eintreten und dann,
den gesamten, um sich diesen gesamten die Kosten für diesen administrativen Overhead, der dadurch entsteht, einfach zu teilen.
Einheitliche Standards da sozusagen draus abzuleiten.
Und auch einheitlicher Standards genau. Und die haben jetzt.
Auch mit der Unterstützung aller dieser Unternehmen und entsprechenden Budgets.
Genau. Und die VG Media hat dann,
gesagt, okay, das mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht, das machen wir auch. Und die hat jetzt große und breit angekündigt, dass sie sich zunächst an die Schietstelle des deutschen Patent- und Markenamts für Urheberrechtsangelegenheiten wenden wird,
um dort auf eine Einigung mit Google hinzuwirken. Und sofern es dort nicht zu einer Einigung kommt, käme,
dann würde es also zu einem Landgericht, zum Landgericht gehen und dann irgendwie den den Weg. Finde ich jetzt mal interessant.
Was, was, was, was klagen sie denn jetzt eigentlich? Also ich meine, sie haben doch selber äh jetzt äh zugestimmt, dass Google äh
ihre Angebote dort
bei News kostenlos haben darf, weil das war doch die erste Reaktion von Google auf die Einführung des Leistungsschutzrechts, dass sie sich da quasi auf so ein Opt-In-Modell eingelassen haben, gesagt haben, ja, ihr müsst aber jetzt hier auch irgendwie ja sagen.
So und dann frage ich mich jetzt so richtig, wo an der Stelle äh das Recht abgezweigt werden soll, da.
Ich denke mal, dass sie versuchen wollen. Also ich ich so, wie ich das jetzt lese, scheint ihre Strategie zu sein. Alle, die irgendwas mit Leistungsschutzrecht machen wollen, schließen sich dem Ding an,
Und dann treten wir alle Google gegenüber und,
sagen, klar darfst du auf uns verlinken, aber übrigens, wir haben da ja noch ein äh ein Recht drauf, dafür zu bezahlt zu werden und dieses Geld hätten wir jetzt gerne. Lass uns doch mal offen Betrag einigen.
Und ihnen ist, glaube ich, nicht klar, dass Google eventuell einfach sagt, ach so, ähm nö. Dann linken wir lieber einfach gar nicht auf euch.
Ich meine klagen Klage heißt ja, dass irgendein Verstoß vorliegt. Wir reden ja jetzt hier nicht äh,
Wir reden ja hier nicht von einem Vorgehen mit Google ein Gespräch zu suchen,
sondern hier soll ja sozusagen eine Klage gemacht werden. Da muss ja für diese Klage muss ja auch in irgendeiner Form eine Beschreibung vorliegen, was denn bitte der Gegenstand dieser Klage ist. Also was wird denn jetzt Google konkret vorgeworfen?
Na ja, im Zweifelsfall würde ich doch davon ausgehen, dass sie Google vorwerfen, dass Google nicht
dem Leistungsschutzrecht entsprechenden Zahlungen leistet oder sich nicht äh nicht dafür interessiert, sich mit ihnen auf Geld zu einigen. Du äh ich kann das jetzt auch nur sehr schwer verteidigen. Das ist ja.
Du sollst das nicht nicht verteidigen. Ich ich verstehe jetzt bloß überhaupt die also den Vorwurf an der Stelle jetzt erstmal noch überhaupt nicht, weil das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen unklar, was jetzt eigentlich falsch getan wurde äh angeblich. Naja, vielleicht hätten wir ja.
Na, sie wollen halt äh irgendwie Geld dafür haben. Also ich meine, dieses Leistungsschutzrecht ist ja dafür da, dass sie Geld bekommen.
Ja gut, aber das
Leistungsschutzrecht sagt ja nicht Google hat so und so viel Geld zu bezahlen sondern steht nur steht den Verlagen frei da eine Lizenz zu vereinbaren weil sie ja darauf ein Anrecht haben und jetzt muss ja quasi auch ein Vergehen vorliegen,
so. Ja.
Ja und das Vergehen ist wahrscheinlich, dass Google sagt, ach so, ihr wollt, dass wir auf euch linken, dann unterschreibt mal bitte hier,
und dann wird wird die VG Media wahrscheinlich sagen, ja, aber die, das ist natürlich und da hat sie wahrscheinlich sogar juristisch recht mit. Wenn jemand dir ein wenn jemand sagt, okay, ich habe einerseits das Monopol auf Suchmaschinen,
Ja, das ist quasi ein Monopol auf Suchmaschinen,
Andererseits hast du ein Recht von mir Geld zu bekommen, wenn ich auf dich linke oder wenn ich verwende, um auf dich zu linken. Und,
wenn du von mir verlinkt werden möchtest, muss ich dich leider bitten, pauschal dieses Recht abzutreten.
Oh, jetzt habe ich hier an dem falschen Regler gedreht, sorry. Ähm,
und dann sagt die, dann sagt die äh dann sagt die VG Media eben, naja, das ist doch nicht in Ordnung. Du kannst ja nicht ein ein Recht, was mir zusteht. Ähm mich zwingen, dieses Recht ähm,
dieses Recht äh nicht wahrzunehmen, wenn du gleichzeitig das tust im Rahmen einer Marktmacht, die du hast. Also ich denke schon, dass sie da ähm,
Jurist aus juristisch betrachtet, durchaus einen einen Case haben.
Ja, aber dieser Case kann doch nur, ich meine, Google hat doch eh schon ein White Listing eingeführt, dass sie sich jetzt quasi von allen äh zugesichert haben, dass äh die das jetzt kostenlos verlinken dürfen, sonst hätten sie's nicht gemacht und dann haben sie auch alle ja gesagt. Was soll man denn dann da einklagen?
Einer Marktmacht, das ist doch das Aussort seiner Marktmacht, wenn der,
wenn der, wenn der Diebsuchmaschine mit neunzig Prozent Anteil sagt, unterschreib mal hier, dass du ein gesetzlich verbrieftes Recht, das du hast,
Abtritts und nicht geltend machen wirst, wenn du in den Genuss meiner Verlinkung kommen möchtest, ich bin aber nur mal der, der überall hinlinkt,
So, also das, ich denke schon, dass das äh juristisch betrachtet, ähm sie da eine Möglichkeit haben.
Na gut, dann müsste diese monopolartige Stellung natürlich auch erstmal ähm äh müsste dann erstmal festgestellt werden und ehrlich gesagt, daher weiß ich nicht, ob das so einfach ist.
Das soll dann auch nicht unsere Sorge sein. Der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass jetzt elf, elf, elf Monate man irgendwie dachte, okay, es gibt Leistungsschutzrichtungen, keiner äh keiner geht hin.
Ja.
Aber äh jetzt gehen sie hin, jetzt wollen wir mal sehen. Äh.
Genau. Stell dir vor es ist Leistungsschutzrecht und keiner geht hin.
Okay, gut. Äh wir sind gespannt, was dabei äh herauskommt. Allerdings hatten wir nicht sonderlich viel äh Hoffnung, dass irgendwas Gutes dabei herauskommt.
Ich habe das, ehrlich gesagt, auch nur deshalb mit ihr die Themen aufgenommen, weil ich weiß, dass jedes Mal, wenn Leistungsschutzrecht gesagt wird, du in dieses Jahr und was soll denn, keine Ahnung, wie soll das denn gehen? Verfällst du das hier nicht.
Ja, ich bin der Pafflasche äh Hund der Netzpolitik.
So, was haben wir noch? Nischt.
Ich weiß nicht, in mir ist jetzt mehr nicht aufgefallen. Es gibt noch kleinere Meldungen. Es gibt kleinere, möchtest du noch kleinere Meldungen.
Kleinkram. Macht auch Mist. Mhm.
Kleinkram, ja. Ähm,
Thomas arbeitet sich gerade Thomas Lohniger, der auch öfter hier Gast ist, arbeitet sich äh gerade an der äh an einem Spotify Deal, ab den es dann jetzt auch in Österreich geben soll. Das heißt
äh ein österreichisches äh Mobilfunkunternehmen. Jetzt muss ich noch ganz schnell schauen, welches ist denn wahr? Ähm,
Hat auch so einen Spotify Deal angekündigt und ähm jetzt äh berichtet Thomas da ausführlich drüber und hat sich dann auch an die,
Regulierungs-, die Regierungsseiten Regulierungsstellen gewendet,
um zu schauen, wie denn mit diesem Verstoß gegen die Netznetralität dort umgegangen wird und er ist da eigentlich ganz guter Dinge, weil die Regulierungsbehörde,
PLRTR,
äh ihm geantwortet und der Mobilfunkunter das Mobilfunkunternehmen, was diesen Deal anbietet, heißt übrigens drei groß geschrieben DERE. Ähm.
Und die die RTR hat also äh aus den Medien daraus erfahren, davon erfahren und zitiert dann so ein paar äh,
Absetze aus dem Telekommunikationsgesetz, die da wahrscheinlich jetzt irgendwie verletzt würden und ähm möchte das jetzt also mal ähm,
prüfen und äh hoffen,
dass dass man da irgendwie gegen gegen vorgehen kann. Allerdings sagen sie, dass sie irgendwie im Moment keinen konkreten rechtlichen Grundlagen gibt, dagegen vorzugehen, aber also Fazit ist, es gibt dieses Problem,
Spotify, jetzt auch in Österreich und Thomas ist dran. Das heißt wir haben gute Chancen,
äh diesen Verstoß gegen ihn jetzt neutralität äh wirksam äh entgegen zu wirken.
Genau, denn wenn wir den, wenn.
Aller Kunden.
Release der Thomas. Genau.
Ja. Also macht euch.
Unsere, unsere Geheimwaffe, ja. Thomas wird alles richten. Mit dem Angriff von Herrn Lunninger wird äh das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Ja und auch aus der Schweiz gibt's äh was äh interessantes zu berichten. Äh denn der Schweizer Nationalrat hat heute eine äh nee, heute ist falsch. Äh vor ein paar Tagen, vor zwei Tagen war das schon. Ähm,
ein Antrag angenommen, äh der die gesetzliche Verankerung der Netznetralität,
betrifft. Und zwar also in der also möchten, dass eine gesetzliche Verankerung der Netzneutralität in das Fernmeldegesetz mit äh aufgenommen wird,
auch sehr schön. Ähm wurde übrigens eingebracht von Balthasar Gladly, das ist der äh von dem. Kirez in der Sendung so äh ausführlich berichtete, der da auch seine Vorratsdaten hat, visualisieren lassen.
Mhm. Der äh Grünen-Abgeordnete.
Grünen Abgeordnete der Grünen Nationalrat Nationalrat heißen die in der Schweiz und hat äh hundertelf Ja-Stimmen bei einundsechzig Nein Stimmen und achtzehn Unterhaltungen bekommen und ähm,
Jetzt muss das aber noch durch den Städterat. Das ist das Äquivalent zum deutschen Bundesrat, in dem dann die,
Vertreter der Kantone sind. Und da hat aber haben die Parteien, die dagegen gestimmt haben,
Nämlich die CVP und die FDP,
eine Mehrheit, das heißt, es und das sind die, die im Nationalrat dagegen gestimmt haben,
Das heißt, it's äh steht halt ein großer Sturm der Telekommunikationslobby ins Haus, in der Schweiz. Ähm die natürlich alles versuchen werden, um diese,
ähm in um diese Motion, wie man das nennt, äh irgendwie äh in ihre Schranken zu weisen.
Ne, wenn wir dann demnächst mal nochmal nachfassen, äh wie sich das weiterentwickelt hat, zumindest gibt's da schon mal äh Bewegung und wenn es nur einzelne Gremien äh sind, die sich dann auch gegen sträuben, ist es ja schon mal besser, als wenn es gänzlich ignoriert wird.
Ja. Also äh,
das Schöne ist halt auch zu sehen, wenn halt Menschen plötzlich einfach mal so einen Antrag vor sich sehen und dann einfach mal vernünftig darüber äh kurz nachdenken, ohne Lobbysturm, welche Entscheidung sie dann so treffen,
und ähm jetzt wird man mal sehen, wie sich das halt in was daraus wird. Also es es kommen ja immer mal wieder gute äh Dinge aus Parlamenten und dann wird man halt sehen, wie sie sich auf dem Weg entwickeln.
Hm. Gut, dann kommen wir mal langsam äh zum Ende. Äh wir machen das nicht äh häufig hier mit den äh Ferngesprächen und nächstes Mal bist du auch schon wieder in der Metaebene, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne.
Ja, also wir werden das noch in Zukunft ein bisschen öfter machen. Wir müssen aber ähm.
Sollte es die Regel werden.
Ja. Werden wir sehen. Es läuft ja, es es funktioniert ja sehr gut. Es funktioniert ja sehr gut. Wir sehen uns hier wunderschön.
Das ist toll. Nur die Zeit.
Es ist ja auch so, Tim, wenn wir Fan-Podcast, ne, dann stopfen wir halt auch der NSA immer mehr ins in den Datenzentrums Rachen, ne? Also, du musst ja so sehen, je mehr wir da.
Das stimmt, die müssen sich's zweimal anhören diesmal.
Je mehr wir da reinpumpen.
Einmal live und dann nochmal, äh weil sie ja sowieso alle unseren Podcast abonniert haben. An dieser Stelle äh grüßen wir.
Bei der Arbeit, weil.
Geheimdienstler auch vom äh BND, die uns hier immer so fleißig äh zuhören, ja? Ich hoffe, es war was äh dabei für euch. Seid nicht so frustriert irgendwie äh so ist das halt in solchen Organisationen
und das Leben ist nicht schön,
Aber auch ihr habt die Gelegenheit, euch äh mal frei zu strampeln und so. Vielleicht liegt ihr ja mal das ein oder andere Dokument auf den Kopierer, dann kann man äh schöne Reisen gewinnen.
So sieht's aus. So, die.
Ansonsten könnt ihr auch für mich immer noch schmuggeln. Also ich habe da,
einige Möglichkeiten, einige Ideen im Kopf für mich irgendwie aus verschiedenen Ländern, ne, Ringtausch, Ringtausch, ihr kennt das Prinzip ja, ihr kennt das Prinzip des Ringtausches, ja. Ne, da machen wir noch.
Genau, genau. So, bevor wir uns hier Kopf und Kragen reden, machen wir mal Schluss.
Ja, machen wir. Ist ja jetzt auch nur noch. Ja, tschau, tschüß, ja, tschüss, Feierabend.
Tschüss.